the southern nevada health district  started administering covid 19 vaccines  to kids ages 5 to 11. right now they're  available on a walk-in basis until the  appointment system is fully updated  sally jeremiah has a closer look at how  the day went  hell district and many other clark  county leaders are encouraging parents  with kids between 5 and 11 to get them  vaccinated even though kova 19 is milder  in children kids can still get sick with  the holidays approaching leaders say  it's the right thing to do vaccinating  children is an opportunity to ensure  that they can stay healthy  continue in classroom learning and  return to their pre-pandemic lives which  is really all we want  in clark county there are more than 200  thousand children who are ages 5 and 11  it's important to note the vaccine has  been tested and deemed safe by the fda  according to the white house nearly a  million school-aged children will be  receiving a covid19 vaccine by the end  of the day today did